[Music]
both in sensors allow these robot cats
to respond to petting and touch they are
designed to provide the joy and stress
relief of real cats without any of the
burden my name is Clark I'm a cat lover
and I will be adopting a robot cat for a
week I love cats cats are life cats our
lifestyle cats are my spirit that's a
real tool until like they do their own
thing I'll do my own thing you know I
already have experience with real cats
why not give a row but a chance
[Music]
oh my god is gonna hate this let's go
you and I I'm gonna be best friends
forever no worries alright so here we
are it's day one with my cat and I'm
excited to see if this robot cat can
rival a real cat all right time to take
my sweet daughter Bertie back to
Brooklyn that's gonna do [ __ ] to your
cat sister alright so I'm about to
introduce my cats to Lola right yeah hey
Lola what's up they'll be a little
checking your cat man no do you not like
your robot cat you never run away from
me robot kitty oh my god who did their
look she's comfortable with you guys
belly-up means that [ __ ] you know what
that means someone on the train was like
trying to get in Stella's attention
which was hilarious I'm like it's
backwards don't do any and she's got
joints like it's supposed to so I wonder
if it's broken one really key feature is
that when the cat is left on and you
don't pay her anything she'll actually
go to sleep and she starts snoring like
it's literally so cute when I work to do
I'll just put it on mute or sooner
ah my cat is doing really well at my
desk my co-workers this is disgusting
and I love that it's not nearly as cool
as I thought it would be so we're about
to walk into yes that's right Lola our
final interview you and I had amazing
times together it feels like actual
company any provides that peaceful
moment that cats are sometimes able to
deliver so my week with Lola right here
has been very interesting it really
reminds me of my real cats when they're
behaving which means when they're hungry
and they need me I'm lazy so not having
to feed the cat or honestly maintain it
at all was great if you're looking for
any cat it's emotional support this
could do the trick this could do the job
but did make me appreciate the touch of
a real Kidder's the response of a real
Kidder's the best part about owning a
cat is like winning it over I prefer to
work for it I don't want a robot that
just likes me instantly there's a lot of
things that robot caters are good for
but what do you got the real thing in
your life don't settle for a robot